how about going to Hannity and tonight
growing concerns in the media mob over
Joe Biden's physical and mental Fitness
is the media about to turn on Joe Biden
we'll know for sure when and if they
ever cover his involvement and Hunter's
foreign business dealings actually Joe's
Farm business dealings Now NBC News the
latest left wing Outlet now sounding the
alarm over the president's deteriorating
condition also the king of late night
Greg Gutfeld will react he'll be on the
program tonight straight ahead and we'll
bring you a developing story out of
Martha's Vineyard tonight where the body
of a chef employed by former president
Barack Obama recovered in shallow water
after he went missing while paddle
boarding near the Obama's 12 million
dollar Seaside estate that didn't have
any room for the immigrants that were
kicked off the island in less than 24
hours all those details coming up but
first tonight's top story it is a hard
reality for Democrats and the media job
Joe Biden might for well very be the the
very most corrupt president in the
history of this country but this isn't
just about Joe and credible bribery
allegations against him this Scandal now
extends to the highest levels of the FBI
and the doj where unelected government
bureaucrats took Extreme Measures to
protect the whole Biden Syndicate the
whole family all while making and taking
equally Extreme Measures simultaneously
to destroy all things Trump and Donald
Trump now for those on the left who are
just tuning in here is an important
lesson we're going to call it Joe
Biden's bribery allegations for
left-wing dummies let's begin with some
breaking news Hunter Biden's former
longtime business partner Devin Archer
he is set to testify before Congress one
week from tonight that is next Monday
and according to the New York Post
Miranda Devine well Devin Archer has
damning new evidence and information
against the big guy himself apparently
we'll learn from him that Joe Biden not
only knew about all of Hunter's sketchy
foreign business deals but acted as a
sort of closer or sweetener to these
foreign transactions that benefited the
family in terms of millions and millions
of dollars and we're now learning that
Archer reportedly witnessed multiple
phone conversations between Joe Biden
and his foreign business partners quote
Hunter Biden would dial in his father
then Vice President Joe Biden on
speakerphone into meetings with overseas
business partners Archer allegedly
witnessed more than two dozen of these
conversations including calls with top
barisma Executives remember a credible
FBI Source last week in that you know
1023 document accused both Joe and
Hunter Biden of accepting five million
dollar bribes from barisma you know
technically he said 5 million for each
Biden that Barista execs did not not
want to pay they thought Hunter was
stupid they thought his dog was smarter
but also had to do so they felt because
Hunter quote would protect us through
his dad from all kinds of problems and
one of those problems was a Ukrainian
prosecutor his name was Victor shulkin
investigating barisma and Hunter for
corruption and what do you know it as
Vice President Joe Biden leveraged one
billion of your tax dollars to get the
prosecutor fired in six hours then he
bragged about all of it on tape take a
look
I had gotten a commitment from
poroshenko and from yachts and yuck that
they would take action against the state
prosecutor and they didn't so they said
they had they were walking out to
Prescott and said no I said I'm not
gonna or we're not going to give you the
billion dollars
they said you have no Authority you're
not the president the president said I
said call him
I said I'm telling you you're not
getting a billion dollars I said you're
not getting the billion I'm going to be
leaving here and I think it was what six
hours I looked I said I'm leaving in six
hours if the prosecutor is not fired
you're not getting the money oh son
you got fired
oh it's one hell of a coincidence right
the very prosecutor investigating
Barista Holdings was forced out by Joe
in six hours and his his son Hunter
continued to get paid money for which he
had no experience this is the same
company involved in the bribery
allegations against Biden the same
company paying his son Millions to sit
on that Board Hunter goes on Good
Morning America a crackhead at the time
had no experience at all whatsoever he
told us in his own words take a look
there's been a a lot of misinformation
about me not about my dad nobody buys
that but it buys this idea that I was
unqualified to be on the board what were
your qualifications to be on the board
of barisma well I was vice chairman of
the board of Amtrak for five years I was
the chairman of the board of the UN
world food program I was a lawyer for
boys Schiller flexner one of the most
prestigious law firms in the world you
didn't have any extensive knowledge
about natural gas or Ukraine itself
though uh no but I think that I had as
much knowledge as anybody else that was
on the board if not more in the list you
gave me of the reasons why you're on
that board you did not list the fact
that you were the son of course yeah no
what role do you think that played I
think that it is impossible for me to be
on any of the boards that I just
mentioned without saying that I'm the
son of the Vice President of the United
States if your last name wasn't Biden do
you think you would have been asked to
be on the board of arisma I don't know I
don't know probably not I I don't think
that there's a lot of things that would
have happened in my life that uh that if
my last name wasn't fine
that's why we're calling this Joe Biden
bribery allegations for dummies like
dummies in the media and dummy Democrats
in the Washington swap we now know what
they were paying for at the very least
according to Archer they had a direct
line to the vice president of the United
States thanks to Hunter the guy that was
in charge of Ukrainian policy and even a
billion of our taxpayer dollars we saw a
similar situation with Hunter's business
partners from China look at that
threatening what's up what's that
message to Hunter's Chinese Associates
quote I am sitting here with my father
and would like to understand why the
commitment made has not been fulfilled
Hunter continued I will make certain
that between the man sitting next to me
and every person he knows and my ability
to hold a grudge that you will regret
not following my direction and I'm
sitting here waiting for the call with
my father a few days later magically
Hunter was wired nearly five million
dollars now the White House claims that
Hunter was addicted to drugs and making
empty threats and that Joe had nothing
to do with it it was most likely not
sitting next to Hunter but around the
same time Hunter was pictured at his
father's house driving Joe's Infamous
family Corvette you know where those
documents were one of four places where
they were with no raid at all now the
big guy himself pictured with many of
Hunter's business partners there
including Devin Archer and here they are
golfing together so it's pretty unusual
to say the least that Joe Biden swore
over and over again that he had no
knowledge at all whatsoever of Biden's
business deals again I'm reminding
everybody because this is the Joe Biden
bribery Scandal allegation for dummies
so I'm putting it all together simply
for you take a look
vice president how many times have you
ever spoken to your son about his
overseas business dealings I've never
spoken to my son about his overseas I
have never discussed with my son or my
brother or anyone else anything having
to do with their businesses period And
what I will do is the same thing we did
in our Administration there will be an
absolute wall between personal and
private uh and and the government do you
stand by your statement that you did not
discuss any of your son's overseas
business yes I stand by that statement
Joe Biden was lying he lied repeatedly
and right on cue his press secretary
still refuses to give any direct and
honest answer to any questions about the
big guy's involvement in his family's
Farm business schemes take a look
Teresa the White House and the president
still stand behind his
I've been asked this question a million
times the answer is not going to change
the answer Remains the Same the
president was never in business with his
son
now there is now a mountain of evidence
and it's building more and more every
day it's taken time because people have
been reluctant resistant been hard to
get suspicious activity reports it was
hard to get a hold of the fd-1023 form
uh and to know that the president of the
United States could be very well up to
his eyeballs and corrupt money-making
schemes with some of our biggest
adversaries and geopolitical foes should
frighten every American there are
photographs there are eyewitness
accounts there are tax records bank
records suspicious activity reports
shell corporations text emails serious
allegations filed with the FBI and
damning concerns raised by career IRS
investigators who came forward as
whistleblowers because they were stymied
again and again and again by their
leadership in other words they were the
bidens were being protected the FBI and
the IRS his false tax return for 2018. a
false tax return that includes huge
proper deductions improper deductions
for prostitutes sex clubs and his adult
children's tuition in November of 2022
the statute of limitations was set to
expire for the 2014 and 2015 Chargers in
DC which included the 2014 felonies for
the attempt to evade or defeat tax and
fraud or false statement regarding
berezma income earned by Hunter Biden in
those years the statute of limitations
have been extended through a tolling
agreement with Hunter buyers defense
counsel and they were willing to extend
it past November 2022
Weiss allowed those to expire the United
States Attorney Weiss told us that he
was not the deciding person that he had
requested and was denied special
Authority after D.C declined charges and
that if California declines you will
have to request special authorities
again I understood the gravity of those
admissions based on what I experienced
that the U.S attorney in Delaware in our
investigation was constantly hamstrung
limited and marginalized by doj
officials as well as other U.S attorneys
I still think that a special counsel is
necessary for this investigation
and after a five-year investigation the
doj only managed to charge Hunter with
two minor misdemeanor tax violations
while letting the clock run out on more
serious charges which by the way this
guy the prosecutor Weiss's office said
had signed off on felony tax charges as
far as we know anyway there's never been
a serious bribery Farah tax
investigation into Joe the big guy
hunter why weren't they charged with
fire violations in the case of Hunter
Biden the federal government is
preparing to throw the book at all
things Donald Trump every second of
every day keep in mind Joe Biden May
what might well be a crook but he won't
be in office forever I'd be surprised if
he makes it to election day without
another catastrophic fall but the
unelected bureaucrats sadly at the
politicized weaponized FBI doj will be
around indefinitely and for the better
part of a decade they have been throwing
cinder blocks now on the scales of
Justice now now on our elections this is
abuse of power it is rotting our
Republic from within and it will only
continue to get worse unless Republicans
take the action needed with serious
reform Personnel decisions all across
the entire federal government hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else